I'm starting on Ivermectin and Medmedizol, what would be better for the liver if one has
hormone-positive breast cancer, Tudka or a product with milk thistle?
So I think the person's asking the question, if I'm on a fedmedizol or Medmedizol and Ivermectin,
that has the potentiality of causing liver congestion and issues with the liver, what would be best
a Tudka product or a milk thistle product to help with that?
I would say milk thistle because milk thistle is going to more directly support the
cytokrome P450 pathway with detoxification and I think that is the issue typically with
the Medmedizol products is that the person just isn't detoxing it well, so you don't have
to detoxify it well.
So I've had people on the Medmedizol and they don't ever have any elevations and AST, ALT
or alkaline phosphates that other people it directly affects it and they have to go off
of it for a period of time and it really gets down to maybe genetics and maybe just other
damage to that person's liver over time that we live 70 years and what damages our liver?
Well our toxic load damages our liver alcohol damages our liver but really bottom line is our
toxic load alcohols of toxins to our liver and that could damage those pathways and we are
not going to be as fast as detoxified as someone who doesn't have those pathways damaged.
So I would say milk thistle but if you have Tudka at home already you can certainly take
that as well.